it's so good to see you congratulations
last night was absolutely amazing there
you are in Skype Jeff is counting the
boats and you bombard it with the votes
or for Natalie two million dollars you
are a legend how have you absorbed
everything that just happened not yet I
haven't absorbed yet but up last night
it was it was amazing to be sitting in
my living room with my family on my sofa
in the comfort of my own home watching
Jeff talk to us from his garage pulling
out the votes
it was just it's definitely gonna go
down in the history books for sure for
sure so what do we call you now do we
call you the legend of all legends do we
call you King legend to be called King
survivor survivor God what do you want
us to call you at this point
so Tony black goes is fine but I don't
want you guys to put a target on my back
if I go out there and play again are you
right you are gonna play again you know
what's so great is this was the ultimate
season of Survivor this was a moment
that we'll never forget it was
absolutely amazing what is it like for
you to be able to say that you won
against all these survivor legends was
that more important to you than the
money itself everything when I do go out
this like a job you know whether I like
it or not I give it my best I always go
into the game without the thoughts of
resumes or resume buildings or making
moves I just go there and I play the
hardest that I can play I give him my
all and I believe that this season it
was my full potential there's I can't do
any better than I did this season I want
immunities I was patient when I needed
to be I I was I struck when I needed to
strike my timing was perfect it's just I
couldn't ask the social game was on
point the strategic game was on point I
don't think I made fire I found idols I
don't think I could have done anything
better or more I really really don't
think so that's a really good point
because when we met in Fiji you talked
about the fact that you are ready to
play the steaming game you're ready to
do the spinous you were ready to do all
that and then you told me
dad you weren't gonna change your game
but I think you played with a lot of
heart this time around Tony and I think
that's why you got no votes through this
whole season yes you know again me I'm
not a person I don't travel much I don't
watch sports I don't care about what I
eat I can eat poop on the ground and
I'll be good as long as I'm full so I'm
really not into anything like that where
these people are so I would just give
him enough dosage of my social game
where I could talk about family what's
it about family I was engaged in
conversations and that's how I bonded
with them once they started talking
about food and traveling in sports I had
to walk away out of there you know so
I'm just give me the right amount of
dosage where they could you know we
could form bonds together socially but
not to be overbearing and that was the
key to my success was just the right
time with everything which is perfect
timing with everything yeah and then you
in the fire challenge and gets all
emotional with you and Sarah there's
that moan of a hugging and there's a lot
of verbal conversation going on there
that we didn't really get to hear did
you know at that point you were about to
win survivor I didn't know but uh Sarah
Lewis with whispering she's like dude
stop being so emotional you probably
just won you just probably won the game
you know like you know you see Sarah
she's way stronger than I am
I was just mess it she's like dude calm
down and she's talking about I want to
battle him I don't care I'm ready you
want to shoot me she's like oh my god
but yeah it was just so I mean last
night watching that I cried more
watching that last night than I did
watching the family visit III mean I
felt that because it was painful last
night yeah it was joyful so it's a
different kind of an emotion you know
yeah yeah and then there's Natalie who
shows up right and a lot of people felt
for her yesterday like maybe she is the
ultimate survivor she went through edge
of extinction for how many days and
she's back at the top and the top three
what did you think of her game listen I
have nothing against Natalie everything
everything that I'm gonna say it's
against the twist of the edge you don't
get voted out first or second or third
or fourth or even tenth and come back
when there's five days remaining and not
only do you come back for five days
remaining you
come back fully loaded with ammunition
with an idol to protect yourself I
believe if you do come back into the
game it's your job to either create a
crack or find a crack in the Alliance
and get yourself through don't come back
with protection and you see what
happened you know Sarah and Ben they
were adamant that she didn't have that
protection and I was like let's just
play it safe just in case I'm not a
psychic I can't tell you for sure the
Ryan I don't but listen a thing let's
split the boats because ultimately what
happened Denise went home but we lost to
idols you know so I was a little upset
with that but uh the twist I mean we
were talking were like there's no way
she could come back with an idol five
days left in the game that's just not
right but guess what this doesn't have
to be right doesn't have to be fair it's
survivor so she if she won it would have
been the right way to win no not as far
as I'm concerned that as far as what was
the 12 other jurors were concerned you
know yeah so after the win last night
did you have a chance to connect with
any of the other contestants did you
guys have a conversation with anybody
not a conversation but we sent texts out
congratulation guys with an epic finale
this was great you know stuff how you
feeling stuff like that but it was very
brief I got over like six seven hundred
messages I didn't even go through right
now my phone it's just a lot of love a
lot of support you know it's just an
amazing I I played the best game that I
don't like the played yeah everybody
appreciated that and they gave me my
props what does Sarah say did she text
you last night
Sarah's tell me dude I hope you're not
crying again she's so strong was there
any particular moment that did not show
up on the show that you wish was on the
show that people have seen um I don't
know about wishing it'd be on the show
but there was a lot I formed tight
alliances with Nick the weather rolled
off was a lot partially doop with Nick
they show that Sophie made the decision
but it was a lot you know Nick told me
that Wendell blindsided you told me
about Michelle
tell me about they were trying to split
tokens so you know there's a lot of
stuff and I went to Sophie and say
Sookie listen Wendell backstab Yul and
then it was just like stuff that wasn't
shown Nick told me about him having an
idol when Nick came back um that
challenge that Michelle was blindsided
and they were fighting I was calming
Nick down Mick says no I'm tired
you know how come nobody's talking to
Kim she has an idol I'm like why so you
know there's so much there was so much
but it wouldn't fit in with the story
that they were showing you know so you
know we have a whole different story and
the editing has a whole dipper story
they want to show her but there was a
lot of stuff there's a lot of stuff and
then when we saw each other in Fiji you
have this battle scar on your foot and
you said to me you said to me if I want
season 40 I'm going to tattoo s40 on the
scar are you going to do it that was a
total I don't believe with this money
especially at a time like this where a
lot of people are going through a fair
amount what does it mean to be able to
secure that for your family oh it's an
amazing feeling of like you know I have
so much debt that I rely on tenants to
pay you know the mortgages on buildings
that I've worked on the first million
that I want to invested it and now just
knowing that listen I don't want to rely
on anybody for my financial security I
won this money it's a blessing let me
just pay off all my debt and just try to
live a comfortable life for at least
nine more years I retired in five years
then I could start chasing that money
all over again but right now I don't
want to chase it no more I was blessed
enough to win this much money I'm tired
of chasing the money yeah and so now
season 40s over it looks like this was a
great way to end it after being on the
show three times how would you describe
this ultimate experience because we're
so all high on the experience last night
but for you to be able to go through and
watch the show connect with people by
text last night how would you describe
the experience for you and being around
these legends it's definitely an honor I
would say it's it's you know like you
know I'm watching the show and I'm
watching how people are portrayed as not
being strategic or real powerful but
they're all winners they all crush their
season they all you know I mean that you
you you not you want to claim season 40
unless you destroyed your season and won
your season no matter what you saw on TV
there was so much behind it that you
didn't see again
I've won the season the editors know I
won the season so they're gonna portray
like I was you know I was this that was
I did play a good game but so did
everybody else yeah high five Tony
congratulations
two million dollars thank you so much
man King survivor forty
I'll see you feed you again thank you so
much